My name is Eslam Hesham, I'm a Front-End Course
manager at udacity
and I would like to give an insight into our
websites development program.
In this program we start with the basics,
from scratch
we don't expect the developers who want to
join
the program to have any skills in the subject
on contrary, we start with the foundations,
so
our first course is introduction to HTML and
CSS
through which we learn how to present our
content on the website
presenting it on the front of the
website in a beautiful and organized way
so that it draws the user to log on to the
website more than once and interact with it.
The job of a front-end developer is very important
in our times
because nowadays every company, every product,
and every application needs to have a front
needs something that expresses or showcases
it
So it's very important that the developer
is up to date with the technology, because
every day there's a new technology emerging
because every day there's a new technology
emerging,
there's a new technology taking over the market
so it's crucial that one is interested in
developing himself, in adding to his knowledge.
I encourage you if you love the topic to participate
in our program
I think it's going to be highly beneficial
for you, allowing
you to be a part of this diverse workforce
and market
you can even work from home if you'd rather,
you don't have to be working in a company,
you can have clients of your own
I think it gives you the freedom to work anytime.
from anywhere making good money like others.